Bags, bottles, diapers, razors, cups, forks, sporks, straws.
The waste generated from these single-use non-biodegradable plastic products...
...sticks around in some form for about five hundred years...
...or six human lifespans.
Scary.
The idea of saving the world from this plastapocalypse may seem impossible,...
...kinda like not instagramming a really fun salad.
Oh, that's cute.
But luckily, even one person can make a huge impact.
Just bring your own.
Going to the grocery store?
Bring your own reusable bag.
The average American uses an estimated 314 shopping bags per year.
What if you brought that number down to one...
...by using a single reusable bag?
This would save all those resources, like freshwater and fossil fuels,...
...that go into manufacturing and shipping.
And that means saying bye...
...to all the CO2 that would've gone into our atmosphere.
But since bags are not the only part of this single-use monster, why stop there?
The average American tosses approximately 185 pounds of plastic per year.
Now, imagine if the 318 million people living in the US...
...chose to only use reusables.
Multiply those actions by the billions of people living on Earth,...
...and the recovery of our planet seems possible.